Por aquí tenemos dos funciones que han
sido definidas de forma visual o gráfica:
a la izquierda tenemos la gráfica de g(x)
y a la derecha tenemos la gráfica de h(x),
y lo que quiero que hagamos es encontrar el lim
g(h(x)) cuando x → 1. Pausa el video e intenta
encontrar la respuesta. Bien, trabajemos juntos.
Lo primero que puedes tratar de hacer es buscar
el lim x → 1 h(x), y cuando lo vemos en la gráfica
¿a qué será igual? Bueno, cuando nos aproximamos a
x = 1 por la izquierda, parece que h(x) tiende
a 2; cuando nos aproximamos por la derecha,
también parece que h(x) tiende a 2, así que parece
que este límite será 2. Entonces, podemos decir
"Tal vez podemos poner este valor dentro de g.
¿Cuánto es g(2)?" Bueno, g(2) es 0, pero el límite
no parece estar definido. Cuando nos aproximamos a
x = 2 por la derecha, parece que g(x) tiende a 0,
y cuando nos aproximamos a x = 2 por la izquierda,
g(x) tiende a -2, así que tal vez este límite no
existe. Pero si lo estás pensando así, nos falta
analizarlo un poco más, porque lo que debemos
hacer es ver este límite en términos del límite
por la izquierda y del límite por la derecha,
así que pensémoslo de esa forma. Primero pensemos
en cuál es el límite cuando x → 1 por la izquierda
de g(h(x)). Bueno, si lo pensamos de esta forma,
cuando nos aproximamos a 1 por la izquierda,
podemos ver que h(x) se aproxima a 2 también por
la izquierda, o podemos decir que se aproxima
a 2 desde abajo, es decir, desde valores menores
que 2; por lo tanto, el valor que pongamos dentro
de g(x) se aproxima desde abajo, desde valores
menores que 2, por lo tanto, lo que pongamos en
g se aproxima a 2 desde valores menores que 2,
es decir, si nos aproximamos a 2 desde abajo,
por aquí, ¿a qué se aproxima g? Parece que g se
aproxima a -2, así que parece que esto será -2,
al menos el límite por la izquierda. Ahora
calculemos el límite por la derecha. ¿Cuál
es el límite cuando x → 1 por la derecha de
g(h(x))? Bueno, podemos hacer lo mismo. Cuando
nos aproximamos a 1 por la derecha, parece que h
se aproxima a 2 desde abajo, desde valores menores
que 2; entonces, si nos aproximamos a 2 desde
valores menores, desde abajo -porque recuerda:
sea cual sea la salida de h, será la entrada de
g-, por lo tanto, si lo que ingresamos en g
se aproxima a 2 por debajo, significa que g, una
vez más, se aproximará a -2. Así que aquí tenemos
un caso muy, muy, muy interesante, donde el lim
g(x) x → 2 no existe, pero cuando nos aproximamos
desde ambos lados, desde la izquierda y desde
la derecha, h se aproxima a 2 desde abajo,
y entonces en ambos casos podemos
pensar en el límite por la izquierda,
cuando nos aproximamos a 2 desde abajo, o desde
la izquierda de g porque en ambas situaciones
nos aproximamos a -2. Así que ese será el límite
que buscamos, cuando el límite por la derecha y el
límite por la izquierda es el mismo; entonces,
ese será nuestro límite, es igual a -2.